hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us for cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast carbapenem a is producing gnb
the nightmare nightmare bacteria are
here to stay I am Julia Oracle black
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's webinar we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
the american society for clinical
laboratory science aaas CLS ascl s makes
a positive impact in health care through
leadership that assures excellence in
the practice of laboratory medicine more
information please visit WWE a large you
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or carrying this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top of right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left following his presentation
head over to the community of learning
in the lab exchange lobby to help the
opportunity to engage in live chat and
have more of your questions answered on
the spot about carbapenem is producing
gnb not near bacteria that are serviced
today I would now like to introduce
today's speaker Nicholas more ms LLS
ascp cm Nicholas more is an instructor
in the department of medical laboratory
science at rush university medical
center Nicholas earned his master of
science degree in clinical laboratory
science at rush university in Chicago
and upon graduation he worked for two
years in the microbiology and core
laboratories at rush university medical
center in 2011 he accepted a position as
a laboratory director
term acute care hospital eltek in
Chicago while in the LTAC he was
involved with investigators in a CDC
funded study that involved the
implementation of an infection control
bundle to reduce klebsiella nouman a car
back enemies kpc transmission and
infection in the alt tag setting is
currently an instructor in clinical
microbiology in the department of
medical laboratory science at rush
university medical center and is a
doctoral candidate his research efforts
focused on kpc other antimicrobial
resistance mechanisms among
gram-negative bacilli i will now turn it
over to nicholas more for his
presentation thank you Judy and thank
you everyone for attending today I am I
was very honored to accept the
invitation to come and give this
presentation so we'll go ahead and get
started I do have just a few disclosures
that are there I'm not going to be
talking about anything commercial today
related to any of these disclosures but
but you have them there for housekeeping
purposes here's today's objective so by
the end I hope everyone is going to be
able to discuss laboratory methods that
can be used to detect clinically
important carbapenem aces to identify
patient level risk factors for KPC
colonization in long-term care settings
and then will end by discussing
recommendations and strategies for
controlling CRE and healthcare
facilities so I'd like to start with
just a quick poll to each of you in the
audience about what method your clinical
laboratory might use to detect CRE so if
you want to take about the next 15 to 20
seconds to answer this question that
would be great so a couple of different
options you could do your lab might do a
broth in Richmond or some culture based
mechanism they could use a chrome agar
to screen for CRE carriage they might
just use a phenotypic method like that
modified Hodge
a PCR test or if you don't know or if
your lab doesn't routinely detect CRE
and clinical or surveillance cultures
that's fine too so a box should have
popped up and you can select which
option best fits what your lab is doing
and then click the submit button
otherwise if you don't wish to answer I
think there's an X in the upper right
corner of that box that appears
alright so let's see what everyone's
responses were so it looks like about 44
most people who responded if they do a
test it looks like you're performing a
phenotypic based method like the
modified Hajj test which is one of the
methods that's been you know well
published and publicized and discussed
about then about an even number of you
don't know if your lab is currently
doing something to screen and then very
few people use pcr and that's not
unexpected and then about the same
amount may use some type of chromogenic
so we're going to discuss each of these
today in a little more detail as we go
on so let's go ahead and just get
started I like to give a kind of a brief
overview just to kind of set the stage
so they're being in here in the US there
are approximately two million healthcare
associated infections or hih a is that
occur annually and that costs the United
States an extra 45 billion dollars in
health care spending and as we have seen
increasing rates of antibiotic
resistance especially among the
gram-negative bacilli and coupled with a
lack of development of new antibiotics
from pharmaceutical companies this has
really created a very dangerous and
important public health crisis and this
is a nice paper that was published about
five or six years ago in the journal
clinical infectious diseases looking at
actual you know hard costs both hospital
costs and then societal costs in
patients who have infections caused by
antimicrobial resistant organisms and
the the kind of three takeaways from
this paper are that patients with these
antimicrobial resistant infections have
increased rates of mortality compared to
patients with non antimicrobial
resistant infections and these patients
also tend to stay in the hospital for
about an extra week to two weeks so
anywhere from six to almost 13 days
additional time spent in the hospital
and all of that correlates to and about
anywhere from 18,000 to a little over
27,000 additional dollars spent in the
hospital care on a per patient basis so
antimicrobial resistance has a huge
impact on not only the health and
well-being of our patients that on our
ability to provide care for them so in
2013 the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention declared that
carbapenem-resistant Enterobacteriaceae
or CRE are an urgent public health
threat CRE is a very broad family or a
broad description so these are the
enterobacteriaceae that are
carbapenem-resistant and specifically
those CRE that are KPC and that they
produce the klebsiella pneumoniae
carbapenem ace that is the most common
mechanism that is encountered worldwide
I'd like to just go briefly over the
beta-lactam antibiotics these beta
lactams can be divided into five kind of
sub groups or families you have your
penicillin derivatives the
cephalosporins the stuff of my sins the
mana back tam aztreonam and then your
four carbapenems on the right all of
these antibiotics are beta lactams are
beta lactam derivatives they are
designed around the similar beta lactam
structure which you can see kind of in
the green shaded ring and that bottom
figure on the slide so that is the
active portion of the antibiotic
beta-lactam ring is what recognizes and
binds to those penicillin binding
proteins in the bacterial cell wall and
when it binds to those penicillin
binding proteins it prohibits and
prevents some key enzymes from forming
those crosslinks and those those bridges
that give the bacterial cell it's a
strength and rigidity and by preventing
that so often forming
those these beta lactams exert their
bacteria seidel or killing effect on the
bacteria now the bacteria are very smart
and have evolved over over time to
Purdue to come up with ways to avoid the
beta lack the activity of the
beta-lactam ring and one way they do
that is by the production of special
enzymes that hydrolyze these rings and
that you can kind of see happening on
the right hand side of the figure where
this beta-lactam ring has been
hydrolyzed and opened up if that
beta-lactam ring has been hydrolyzed
then the beta lactam can no longer
recognize and bind to those penicillin
binding proteins the antibiotic doesn't
prevent those trans peptidases from
forming the bacterial cell wall remains
formed and strengthened and the bacteria
continue to survive so the carbapenem
aces are carbapenem hydrolyzing
beta-lactamases that confer carbapenem
resistance among these gram-negative
rods now there are a lot of ways that
bacteria can become resistant to
carbapenems and this is very distinct
from enterobacteriaceae and other
gram-negative rods that produce that
possess efflux pumps or have alterations
that lead to pouring mutations which
prevent the drug from entering the
bacterial cell now what we've what some
people have done is taken these
carbapenem ace enzymes and organize them
into a classification system and this is
based on the homology between the amino
acid sequences and this is the ambler
molecular classification system so for
the for the ones that I'm going to talk
about today you're carbapenem aces that
fall into class a C or D I'll share a
serine residue kind of at the center of
this enzyme and that's what gives that
enzyme its act it's a
logic activity in contrast your class
the enzymes which are also known as the
metallo beta-lactamases instead of
possessing a searing molecule they have
a divalent cation like zinc in the
center for their activity this is a
table just kind of going over some some
key points of the three carbapenem aces
that we're going to talk about today kpc
MDM and the newest to kind of show its
face here in the US the AXA 48 like
carbapenem aces all of these are found
on plasmids which leads to their very
high potential for dissemination across
bacterial species and also to other
patients but they have varying levels of
activity to some of these beta lactams
and this can kind of be a clue when you
look at a susceptibility report about
what potential carbapenem ace may be
present and we'll talk more about that
towards the end so if you look at
organisms that produce the KPC
carbapenem ace for example they
typically have hydrolytic activity
towards all beta lactams so in other
words all of the beta lactams that you
might test are going to typically be
resistant or have very high mi seas in
contrast organisms that produce the ndm
gene are going to still remain resistant
to all beta lactams except for the mono
back to ms tree mmm so if you're
resistant to all of your beta lactams
good as tree and am remains susceptible
it's a very high possibility that the
organism is producing a carbapenem ace
that's MDM and then the ox of 48 like
carbapenem aces are often the most
difficult to try to identify without
molecular typing or PCR methods and
that's because they have relatively weak
hydrolytic activity of the carbapenems
the mi seas are going to be slightly
elevated or you know just but very much
lower compared to a pc or ndm and they
also remain usually
to your later third-generation
cephalosporins so ceftazidime
ceftriaxone ceftazidime and ceftriaxone
and and those other later generation
cephalosporins unless the organism is
also an esbl producer or possesses again
alterations in the porn porn mutation or
an efflux pump so the oxy 48 are the
typically the hardest to identify just
using phenotypic methods alone this was
the paper that was published back in two
thousand and one that really described
the first bacteria I was a klebsiella
pneumoniae that produced the klebsiella
pneumoniae carbapenem ace and again this
has really become the most clinically
important carbapenem ace that we're
seeing worldwide since its initial
description in 2001 it has spread
throughout the United States and also
spread globally and that has two wrote
that is really due to the fact that it
can be found on this very mobile
transposon that can then be inserted
into plasmids from a lot of other
gram-negative rods so that's really what
allows for it to spread so easily in
Chicago kpc was first identified in our
region back in 2007 and it was
identified in a patient who was
transferred to a West Suburban Medical
Center from a skilled nursing home in
Northwest Indiana
in 2000 later in 2008 rush my
institution received their first patient
who also came from a post acute care
facility a long-term acute care hospital
or an LTAC in Northwest Indiana as well
so I don't know what Indiana's been
doing but they've really been
introducing a lot of bad bugs to the
Chicago area um and it was really with
that introduction and that first patient
who was recognized in Chicago that that
kind of really energized some infections
disease practitioners and scientists
here at rush so we did a study that
looks at how this organism was spread
and introduced so I really like this
figure was published in this paper by
Sarah Juan in 2011 and clinical
infectious diseases and what you're
looking at is a modified social network
analysis so when we think about social
network analysis you're typically
looking at interactions between between
people and in this case instead of
looking at interactions between people
we're looking at interactions between
different healthcare facilities and the
types of friends if you will that they
share in common so what we found is that
in this retrospective kind of look back
study there were forty patients who were
identified and they are represented by
the blue triangles who were found to be
KPC positive either under surveillance
or clinical cultures they a majority of
these patients had a direct exposure to
this red circle in the center which is
this a particular long-term acute care
hospital or attack and these patients
spread throughout the metropolitan
Chicago area to 14 different acute care
hospitals which are these kind of golden
yellow circles and also to 10 additional
nursing homes which are the kind
lightly shaded green circles so in total
this one facility kind of played a role
as an epicenter or for this focal point
of this outbreak that gave or
transmitted KPC to 40 different patients
that affected 26 healthcare facilities
in the metropolitan Chicago area so I
think this is a very striking figure
that kind of shows how just how quickly
and this was only a few months in which
this occurred and only two case patients
in this study patients 7 and 17 you can
kind of see them in the lower right
corner were not directly linked back to
this this LTAC in the epicenter of the
outbreak and again this figure just
wants to is really just here to show you
again how quickly KPC that kpc
carbapenem ace has spread throughout the
the country since its initial
description in 2001 up until now I was
at an infection control conference
yesterday so my slide is out of date of
course but as of as of yesterday they're
have have been reported cases of kpc
identified in Alaska so we should shade
Alaska in green and the lower right so
only two states don't have any reported
and confirmed cases of KPC producing CRE
that's Maine and Idaho but again in a
relatively short time this enzyme has
spread quite rapidly throughout the
country and again also throughout the
world that I don't have any figures to
show you but it's prevalent very it's
very prevalent in parts of Europe and
Asia and the Middle East so why do we
really need to care about k pc or other
cre really that has this is a nice study
that was published back in 2008 looking
so this was a case control study looking
at case patients who are infected with a
carbapenem
distant klebsiella pneumoniae so those
are the the this is the bar shaded in
blue and then they were compared 12 12
patients who were infected with a
carbapenem susceptible strain of
klebsiella pneumoniae and the case
patients were matched to controls based
on their site of infection so what we
see overall is that our case patients so
those who had a carbapenem-resistant k
pneumo infection were about three and a
half three point seven times more likely
to die forty-eight percent versus twenty
percent to patients who had a carbapenem
susceptible pay me more infection and
that was just for overall mortality and
that result was statistically
significant you can see the p-value
there and then if we look at
attributable mortality so patients who
died directly as a result of their
infection again attributable mortality
case patients thirty-eight percent
versus twelve percent so four and a half
times more likely to die if you have a
carbapenem-resistant infection versus a
carbapenem susceptible infection so
really just that these these bugs can
spread very rapidly and if patients
develop an infection they have very you
know high rates of mortality associated
with them so kind of just to wrap up
briefly on KPC it's rapidly emerged as
an epidemiologic important mechanism of
resistance in gram-negative bacilli that
our multidrug-resistant they have very
high rates of mortality other studies
looking at the same thing show rates
between thirty and fifty percent
mortality rate if patients develop an
infection and there are a lot of how KPC
has been able to spread so rapidly is
due to this dissemination of this hyper
epidemic clonal type multilocus sequence
type st 258 so multilocus sequence
typing is just basically a way to look
at the the fingerprint if you if you
will of the organism to deter to give it
a discernible a type it type similar to
pfge but we're actually looking at seven
different house
keeping genes that are usually typically
readily conserved they're amplified by
pcr and then they're looking for
mutations in the in the amino acid
sequence of these genes and every time a
new mutation is identified it gives it a
new a new sequence type so my colleagues
and infectious diseases like to talk
about the resistance iceberg and I I was
told if I was going to give this talk I
had to mention it as well so when we
when we think about an iceberg there's
kind of what you see on the surface of
the water which is what's you know
floating and this really represents
those patients who are clinically
infected with a carbapenems producing
organism so these are patients who have
a some type of clinical culture could be
blood urine sputum and evidence of an
infection they could have a high white
count fever signs of you know sirs or
sepsis hypertension rapid heart rate but
there's documented a document its source
and clinical signs of infection what we
have to worry about though is everything
that's happening beneath the surface
that we can't see and this really
represents the patients who are
asymptomatic alee colonized or are
carriers of CRE producing bacteria in
their gut so these are patients who are
rectally colonized who don't show signs
of an active infection they they don't
have a high white count they're not
febrile and really you only detect these
patients if you're looking for it on a
surveillance culture and why this is so
important and why this is really the
large part of this resistance iceberg is
that these are the patients who if you
don't know that they have it they will
go unrecognized and if they're not
placed on contact precautions they're
not isolated these bacteria can be
spread to other patients and other
healthcare facilities either directly or
indirectly via healthcare worker hands
so unrecognized colonization is what
really i think led to a lot of the high
rates and some of these facilities that
we're going to look
briefly just to go over them at a low
beta-lactamases or the MBL s again this
is your class b carbapenem aces visa
again are dependent upon zinc in order
to hydrolyze the beta lactam now
interestingly these are able to be
inhibited by EDTA as I'm sure many of
you are familiar this is an eye on or
cation key later so we can use this in a
in a method in a culture based method to
presumptively identify an MBL if we
compare and EDTA inhibitor with a
carbapenem and i'll describe that here
in a little bit the first MBL was
actually described in japan in 1991 it
was the blah imp metallo beta-lactamase
enzyme and since then dozens if not
hundreds of others and variants on these
other metallic beta-lactamases that i've
been identified now some MBL czar
naturally occurring and chromosomally
encoded in species we don't have to
worry about them they're encoded in a
chromosome they're not an infection
control emergency they're not going to
be spread easily between different
bacterial species we do worry about the
MBL s like MDM and them and imp because
they are found on plasmids and other
mobile genetic elements like trance
integrins and those can be readily
disseminated and those are an infection
control emergency so nvm or the New
Delhi metallo beta-lactamase was the was
probably the one that if you've heard of
our most familiar with it was first
described also in an isolate of
klebsiella pneumoniae this was found or
isolated in a sweetest patient who had
spent some time hospitalized in india
before he returned and was repatriated
to his country back in december of 2009
so again MDM like KPC is found on a
plasmid but indium tends to be a little
more complex and unpredictable when you
compare it directly with klebsiella
pneumoniae car
phenomeus or kpc like kpc it's not
restricted only to k pneumo we find it
in other strains of enterobacteriaceae
there have been outbreaks of MDM coli as
well as a reports of ND m equal a key in
the literature but really along with k
pisi and diems can be recovered from any
nth row bacteria see a member this is
probably something that maybe some of
you might have heard about and others
maybe not but in Chicago another claim
to fame aside from you know the Cubs and
the Blackhawks Chicago was the cited
here in the US of the the largest MDM
outbreak that's been reported so far so
this was an outbreak that was published
in the Journal of the American Medical
Association back in 2014 that was linked
to an ndn producing ecoli that was
associated with patients who had been
exposed to do Oh Dennis scopes those are
a kind of a very fine instrument with a
camera that kind of is passed through
the esophagus through the stomach to
visualize into the small intestinal
tract and into the biliary tree for a
procedure called ERCP endoscopic
retrograde cholangiopancreatography try
saying that three times fast but anyway
this outbreak investigation in summary
identified 44 patients who had been
exposed and had rectal carriage of nvme
core why after undergoing this ERCP
procedure in a suburban Chicago hospital
now what makes this outbreak a little
different compared to some others that
are associated with bacterial
contamination of endoscopes or drag
noscopes is that you know public health
officials cdc experts and the device
manufacturers when they came in and
assisted this facility
they're outbreak investigation found
that and were able to recover this
organism after it had been and after the
instruments had undergone manual
cleaning as well as high-level
disinfection infection and the public
health officials at from Eddie pH and
CDC we're not able to identify any you
know lapses in the cleaning procedure
that the facility was using to service
these scopes so that really was another
clue that maybe there was something
wrong with the design of these scopes
which again came up when we started
hearing in the popular press a few
months back about the outbreak it that
affected the UCLA medical center and
that outbreak that affected UCLA was due
to a different carbapenem ace please or
this was the ox cart up enemies family
these are your class D carbapenem aces
also known as the oxacillin aces that
are associated with carbapenem
resistance now there are several hundred
types of AXA enzymes and I really tried
to group them into five sub families and
the subfamily that's been associated
with this outbreak is the AXA 48 like
carbapenem a switch is found on a
plasmid along with oxide 23 box of 24 40
and acts of 58 the only one that is
chromosomally encoded is ox affif t1 and
those are intrinsic and so far i believe
had only been recovered and isolated in
species of acinetobacter belmont so the
UCLA outbreak a few months back was due
to anoxia 48 like carbapenem ace back in
February on februari 18 the fist the
facility notified a hundred and
seventy-nine patients that they may have
been exposed to CRE bacteria during
their ercp procedure again this was
linked to these do oddness cope
last I checked seven patients had been
actively infected and two of whom
actually did die as a result of not
necessarily attributed to their
infection these are patients who are
already very chronically sick but two
patients did die after undergoing this
ercp procedure so there's been again a
lot in the popular press you may have
seen some of these are very similar
headlines and really this is kind of
again I think highlighting why
antimicrobial resistance is so important
why this is a topic that we should be
discussing and why I was glad to see
last week that the the federal
government and the White House held a
summit or a conference on this topic and
what how the federal government is going
to respond to not only these outbreaks
of CRE but other and multi
drug-resistant infections and bacteria
and what we can do to incentivize
pharmaceutical companies to develop and
make more antibiotics diagnostics
companies to come up with faster and
better ways to identify these organisms
and bacteria more quickly and how we can
know better provide care for patients
with infections caused by MDR rose so
here in Chicago as a result of a
legislative mandate that required
hospitals to screen their ICU patients
for carriage of methicillin-resistant
Staph aureus investigators here at rush
to started something called the realm
project so it stands for a regional
evaluation of a legislative mandate and
this is a voluntary network of hospitals
in the city of Chicago acute care
hospitals that have more than 10 ICU
beds and all long-term acute care
hospitals in Cook County
so investigators go out every six months
and conduct point prevalence screenings
of all of the patients in the facility
at one given day and we screen them for
rectal carriage of CRE we begin
screening for KPC only in 2010 and then
in 2013 we expanded our screening to
screen for KPC as well as MDM what we
found as a result of that at first
initial survey when we were looking for
just kpc when we looked at the 24 acute
care hospitals that were participating
in that survey 15 short stay acute care
hospitals out of 24 had patients who
were rectally colonized with black APC
producing bacteria so out of about 910
patients only 30 in these acute care I
see us were rectally colonized in
contrast when we went to the seven
long-term acute care hospitals or eltax
all seven facilities had patients who
were rectally colonized with KPC
producing bacteria and it was a hundred
and nineteen patients out of 391 in
total who were surveyed so roughly about
three percent of adult ICU patients
versus thirty percent of LTAC patients
so it's a nine-fold increase in the
prevalence of kpc producing bacteria
found in patients with rectal
colonization between these two different
facilities and that was very telling and
striking to us and that really is why we
thought that L tax would be a facility
where we would need to really intervene
if we were trying to try to get a handle
on the spread of these organisms and
these bacteria on a more regional level
so we're not really so much care
concerned about the facility level but
we're concerned about how these bacteria
are spreading in the region
I don't know if many of you are familiar
with long-term acute care hospitals that
these are specialty facilities that are
designed to provide care to patients for
an extended duration of time their
average length of stay as 25 days
compared to a short stay hospital which
is about five to six days and these are
patients who are you know medically
complex and they often have long-term
chronic illnesses these patients require
mechanical ventilation long term
multiple antibiotic therapy and they
have very complex wound care needs so
these are very very sick patients and
this is a figure from the Medicare
Payment Advisory Commission they publish
this report on a yearly basis kind of
showing you how Alta um Medicare money
is being spent so in 2012 there were 420
eltax nationwide that receive Medicare
payments and they Medicare spent about
five and a half a billion dollars in
2012 to provide care and reimbursement
for these services and I should
apologize I was not paying attention to
my Q&A box that was flashing at me dr.
road is on this webinar and he's been
sending me some messages so I'm sorry I
wasn't addressing those but dr. Roe does
a lot of work with MRSA and he's seeing
that prevalence of CRE is really
paralleled to mersa and I am I agree
with that here in Chicago we don't
screen our LTAC patients for mrs a as
part of the realm surveillance but i do
know from my own experience that these
LTAC facilities do also do have high
rates of MDR O's in general and yes I
agree EBS has long complained that there
are a lot of problems with the duodenum
scopes and getting them adequately
cleaned and we'll try to pay more
attention if you guys do have questions
that pop up so please do send them okay
anyway so when we look at the
zeltiq patience and there have been a
lot of studies and I really couldn't
just pick one to to highlight them but a
lot of authors and researchers liken
eltax to being this perfect storm you're
putting the sickest of your sickest
patients in a facility so these
medically complex patients with a lot of
comorbid conditions obesity diabetes
high blood pressure wounds infections
heart failure respiratory failure excuse
me all of these chronic and severe
medical conditions and because these
patients are so sick and many of them
have central lines foley catheters many
of them are on mechanical ventilation so
there's this very high rate of medical
devices that are being utilized and
because again these are the sickest
patients who have a lot of antibiotics
posure in the LTAC setting in the acute
care facilities and they have repeated
exposures at multiple levels and
repeated visits to various health care
facilities this really leads to this
convergence of these risk factors that
makes eltax really the the perfect place
to breed I think the next super bummer
which is why again when we looked at how
we could try to best come up with a plan
to affect the and control the spread of
kpc and other CRE in the Chicago region
we really felt eltax we're an area where
it was going to be very crucial for us
to develop an infected effective
infection control bundle or regimen
because these patients as they get worse
they tend to cycle back to the acute
care facilities because their medical
needs change they require different
levels of care they may return to the l
tax or as they get stable and progressed
they return maybe to their homes or to a
skilled nursing facility for you know
extended durations of nursing care so
these are patients who are cycling in
and out of the healthcare system at
various different levels so why is it
important now
talking about the lab why do we have to
distinguish the mechanism of
carbapenem-resistant and that's really
because if you rely solely on your mi SI
result it doesn't tell you what the
mechanism of resistance might be it's
just going to tell you that yes this
isolate is resistant or it's susceptible
to the drug now some resistance
mechanisms as I said kpc and ND mr on
plasmids those are the ones that are an
infection control emergency those are
the ones that we need to identify
quickly to isolate these patients put
them on contact precautions to try to
minimize the spread of these organisms
other carbapenem aces like the Smee
enzyme SME is a chromosomally encoded
carbapenem ace that's found exclusively
in strains of serratia marcescens
because it's on a chromosome it's not an
infection control risk we don't need to
necessarily isolate these patients
because this this mechanism this
carbapenem ace isn't going to spread so
really knowing what your resistance
mechanism is is really going to help
guide your next steps and and that's why
you know the laboratory the clinical
microbiology lab plays such an important
role in the identification of these
patients and how your facility can then
handle them as a result so in 2010 the
clinical laboratory of the State
Standards clinical and laboratory
standards institute excuse me revised
their break points for the carbapenem
antibiotics to allow facilities to try
to detect carbapenem ace producing
bacteria a little more easily so what
you see on the left are the previous
break points you can see these break
points were much higher susceptible to
ma pennon was less than four resistant
was greater than or equal to 16 once
they were revised the those break points
work drops by about 2-fold dilutions so
susceptible now 2m opinon is an mi see
of less than or equal to 1 microgram per
mil
and it's resistant if it's greater than
or equal to four micrograms per mil so
that was a way to try to help labs
detect these organisms because they were
sliding through with these high-end i
sees you know automated systems weren't
detecting them they weren't calling them
as carbapenem-resistant or carbapenem
ease producers so there was a lot of
there was a lot of unrecognized or
undocumented CRE that was occurring in
clinical isolates so there's a lot of
different tests that laboratories can
utilize to try to identify I'm only
going to talk about a few the first is
the modified Hajj I think it's the one
that people are most familiar with in
the modified Hajj test we're actually
taking our our test isolate our organism
and we are using it in conjunction with
a susceptible strain of E coli we're
using this atcc 2592 to it's a pan
susceptible e.coli that should be
susceptible to all antibiotics when it's
tested so you you make a point 5 pick
Farland standard in the micro lab you
make that of your you're susceptible
ecoli and then you make a one to ten
dilution in normal saline and you streak
it to a Mueller Henson plate to create a
lot of confluent growth and then you
drop your carbapenem antibiotic down on
your plate it's best to utilize mirror
pentam as your antibiotic of choice and
what you do is after overnight
incubation of course the antibiotic is
going to diffuse out from that disc into
the auger and the surrounding area you
take your isolate that you suspect may
produce a carbapenem ace and you're
going to streak it out away from the
carbapenem disc towards the edge of the
plate after overnight incubation what
you're looking for is this zone of
growth of your e coli which really
serves as this indicator if the test
isolate that you're testing Purdue
is a carbapenem ace that carbapenem ace
is going to be present in the
surrounding auger and it's going to
hydrolyze any of the carbapenem
antibiotic around that slant that streak
of your test I slipped and that is
what's going to allow the e.coli to kind
of grow into this into this kind of
indented shape as you kind of see it
almost looks like a pacman to me so he's
kind of where there's growth of your e
coli in contrast here on the right you
see the same test isolates been struck
but you have a nice even circular zone
of inhibition so this test isolate did
not produce a carbapenem ace so this is
your modified hodge negative organism
and on your left is your modified hodge
positive organism the Hajj test is
really easy to perform unfortunately a
lacks specificity it is very poor it's a
poor indicator or poor test to try to
screen for metallo beta-lactamases like
MDM and like with all culture based
mechanism methods it does require an
overnight incubation so it takes a lot
of time another culture based method
this one is designed to kind of overcome
those barriers of the Hajj test from NB
LS is to utilize an me test strip that
has on one end a carbapenem antibiotico
room which you can see here on the right
and then on the left is a carbapenem
antibiotic meropenem with an inhibitor
which is what the I indicates on your
strip so again eat tests look at a
density and antibiotic density of
antibiotic gradients typically
increasing in a doubling dilution so the
presence of an metallo beta-lactamase is
indicated when you have a reduction of
your carbapenem mi SI alone by greater
than or equal to 3
aleutians of your carbapenem antibiotic
in the presence of EDTA which is your
inhibitor so it's on the side but I've
written so the mi c of the carbapenem
with EDTA is 0 point 0 32 and the MSC of
the carbapenem alone of this organism is
2 so the ratio is of the carbapenem to
the carbapenem in the inhibitor is about
a 60 three-fold increase in the dilution
so this indicates presumptively that
this isolate is producing a metallo
beta-lactamase now because its
phenotypic it does require confirmation
but it's a good screen again it's very
sensitive only works for mpls it's very
easy to perform a but again like with
culture methods and their modified haj
it does suffer an overnight incubation
so it gives it a little longer of a
turnaround time now the carpet MP test
is probably isn't other phenotypic
method now this method can identify
carbapenem aces and it actually can
differentiate between three carbapenem
aces your Class A Class B and Class D
this is a phenotypic method that looks
at the acidification of the
acidification reaction based on the
hydrolysis of any panem alone and in the
presence of tazobactam and EDTA as
inhibitors carbon NP test was actually
included in the 2015 updates of the clsi
and 100 as a as a test that labs could
utilize to screen for carbapenem
carbapenem ace production I like this
test it's actually very quick you can
get results in as little as 15 minutes
but you do incubate these tubes for a
maximum of up to two hours the problem
with this test is that you're looking
for a change in colour and the changes
are reds and oranges or dark red and
light orange so its color specific
to you it relies on a visual
interpretation these colors don't last
for very long so you have to read them
at these set points and if you try to
read them beyond two hours the test
isn't valid it's nice so you get the
same you can get the results in the same
day with a matter of hot with it within
a few hours but there's some difficulty
in trying to interpret it now I've read
that there are some commercial
manufacturers that are trying to
commercialize this make it a little more
make the colors a little more stable and
make it a little easier to perform but
as of right now it is a very much a
manual process and you have to make up
all of these hydrolysis solutions and
buffers the day of that they're going to
be used because they don't they're not
very stable so more complex to perform
but it can differentiate and you get the
results the same day but there are some
drawbacks chromogenic media this is an
area that I I would like to see more
being done by some of the manufacturers
most of the chrome agar plates for KPC
or other CRE right now our research use
only the problem with these is unlike
our chrome agar plates former so which
are you know kind of a diagnostic
definitive and approved for their use
most of these at least the ones that I'm
familiar with again our research use
only they haven't been approved by the
FDA yet here in the US and they are not
they don't provide a definitive ID there
are they use a chromogenic substrate and
then a carbapenem and the auger face but
carbapenem-resistant organisms that are
resistant to carbapenem antibiotics
leader through amp sees or foreign
changes can grow on these honors and
produce this these these pigmented
colonies so there's a several studies
out that have looked at them with
varying varying levels of sensitivity
and specificity so not quite as good as
a more
if you use them they really have to be
confirmed with some type of confirmatory
a say this is a something that's fairly
new the Roscoe disks these are
antibiotic impregnated discs they're
much larger than the typical Kirby Bauer
discs but they are utilized kind of in
conjunction with um you have a
standalone carbapenem dis and then you
have carbapenem discs that are
supplemented with various inhibitors and
this is a way to differentiate between
different mechanisms of carbapenem s
resistance I realized the figure might
be a little hard to see but what you're
what you're doing is you take your
isolate you again a point five mcfarland
streak it overnight on to mueller hinton
auger and drop these various discs and
you're looking at changes in zone size
between a carbapenem disc alone and a
carbapenem disc with a particular
inhibitor so the these Roscoe disc it's
can be utilized to differentiate between
kpc and DMS and other metallo
beta-lactamases oxa like carbapenem aces
and then amp see producers so in this
particular diagram we're looking at the
difference between a carbapenem
antibiotic alone which is this disc kind
of in the bottom on the middle with a
zone size of about twenty six
millimeters and we're comparing that to
the zone of inhibition around a disc
with two inhibitors and this phenotypic
pattern and these changes in the zone
size between the carbapenem disc alone
are strongly indicative of in this case
an amp see producer so this was done by
one of our research fellows and
published presented last fall at the ID
week meeting in Philadelphia
now the the best test that you could do
to look for carbapenem aces are
molecular detection methods so doing
some type of PCR assay here we're
looking for the detection of the actual
carbapenem asa gene so most of these
assays if they can be done real-time
would be obviously the fastest
turnaround time so we're looking at
primers to bind to a template a
bacterial genome around your gene of
interest and then utilizing
sequence-specific DNA probes that have
fluorescent tags labeled to detect
fluorescence on your real time analyzer
you know we're pros about pcrs and it's
obviously very rapid you can get results
in a usually right around an hour or
just under an hour but these are very
expensive most of these assays have been
laboratory developed and validated on
their own the CDC has published and
released their multiplex KPC ND ms a
protocol that can be run on an ABI 7500
real-time instrument and I've listed the
reference there for you they describe
their procedure they list they give you
their primer and probe sequences so it's
just up to you if your facility would
like to move to pcr and have the
capability but again it's only been
validated their procedures validate that
a validated on the ABI 7500 I am
familiar that a few diagnostic companies
are looking at platforms that have the
ability to directly detect some
carbapenem aces direct from positive
positive blood culture bottles both the
bio fire has a blood culture ID panel
that can detect KPC maybe india mine
okay pc target is in there and then the
nanosphere ver gene also has a similar
panel that can detect KPC directly from
positive blood culture bottles which is
great but unfortunately again those are
only from pop those are only approved
for use in positive blood culture
bottles and no other specimen types
briefly
you just going to talk about strategies
that the CDC recommends these are can be
found an outlined and their toolkit for
control of carbapenem-resistant
Enterobacteriaceae hand hygiene is
number one making sure your health care
workers are performing hand hygiene both
before and after patient contact and you
know constantly educating them on why we
have to perform hand hygiene contact
isolation so getting these patients
isolated and in contact precautions to
try to prevent the spread getting rid of
medical devices when they're not needed
curr warding patients is appropriately
antibiotic stewardship and again the lab
plays a role because if the lab doesn't
communicate that these organisms are out
there then these are going to spread and
then active surveillance and chg bathing
so active surveillance really these are
your gut bacteria so the rectal isolates
have been shown to be the most sensitive
and finding and recovering KPC positive
kpc producing and drove back to
yesterday you can also look at
combinations of non of rectal and
England all skin sites because again if
patients are stewing there can be a lot
of school in the England area so you can
also recover these organisms for as well
so why active surveillance is important
again this is going to let us know who
has KPC if we do active surveillance we
can identify these patients and then we
can separate these patients to and
establish you know either KPC positive
or k p c- cohorts to prevent the
transmission and in illinois our
communicable disease code was amended
and we are health care facilities and
laboratories are required to notify the
state of all carbapenem-resistant
Enterobacteriaceae isolates that have
been identified in your facility per
patient per an arm for every admission
so we have to report the first CRE
isolate for patient permission and this
began in no
member of 2013 briefly because I'm
running out of time I just want to go
over chg bathing chlorhexidine gluconate
this is a topical antiseptic that is
very powerful and it reduces skin
bioburden and has been utilized for
probably about 50 or 60 years in health
care settings this is a showing how
applying chg on to patients skin sites
and achieving a minimal inhibitory
concentration of CH t greater than 128
micrograms per mil on the skin leads to
an overall reduction in your relative
risk for having KPC positive bacteria
that can be recalled recovered from your
skin sites and as my colleague dr. Bob
Weinstein always talks about a Kleenex
Allah is a happy xilla so this is
showing you a diagram of a skin culture
from an axial Airy site on a patient in
an LTAC both before and after a chg bath
was given chg bath was given so before
the plate is just covered with bacteria
on the left and on the right hand side
you can see immediately after that chg
back there was virtually no bacteria
detected so again chg has been used for
many years in health care settings as a
way to prevent bloodstream infections
and to reduce skin burden I'm not going
to go over this slide I know the slides
are going to be posted as a resource but
this was a kind of clinical culture
results of our intervention looking at
how our bundled intervention had an
effect on reducing the colonization and
infection of kpc positive isolates in
blood cultures and all clinical cultures
and blood culture contaminant blood
culture contamination data I really want
to get to at least
or two of these this is kind of another
an interactive session so i have a quick
case here there was a 51 year old or 52
year old male nursing home resident who
was bedridden with a g-tube of foley and
a tracheostomy and a multidrug-resistant
klebsiella pneumoniae was isolated from
a sacral wound culture here is the
susceptibility reports in the
antibiogram and this isolate was also
tested by the modified hajj you can see
his isolate is this one up here in the
upper corner so kind of based on what
we've learned today what carbapenem ace
do you think is most likely present
again this is going to be another poll
question do you think it's the KPC back
carbapenem ace ndm oxa 48 are you unable
to determine what the enzyme might be so
just take a few quick you know 15
seconds or so to think about that
okay let's go ahead and close that hole
and see what you guys thought and then I
will explain kind of what the the
carbapenem aces all right so 71 percent
set kpc and you are correct so let's
take a quick close look and I'll see why
it might be why it's kpc so if we go
back and look at the susceptibility
profile as you look at this it was
tested by pcr and was locked a pc
positive if you look at your beta-lactam
antibiotics in the panel you'll see that
all of the beta lactams that are tested
are resistant in addition the hajj test
as you can see here if you can interpret
it there is growth of your e coli
indicator organism around the strain
that you're testing so again the
modified haja test is most often and
most sensitive for KPC carbapenem aces
and then we did a PCR test and found qpc
I will go through Oh wah will do one
more and we'll have to skip the third
one but you'll see it in the handout
this was a 65 year old female patient
who had traveled to to Pakistan to visit
her family three months previously she's
now been hospitalized with respiratory
failure secondary to an exacerbation of
COPD and she's been placed on a
mechanical ventilator she had a positive
sputum culture fever and white blood
count grew out an e coli here's this
here's the micro scan panel which you
can see here so we're going to push out
just the same question again so if you
want to take just a quick look and think
about it
here's your modified Hodge test and in
this instance the patient isolate I'm
sorry is right here on the left and your
poor question might be covering it up
but your hot chest will say is negative
so what carbapenem ace is most likely
present is it the KPC and DM oxa 48 or
are you unable to determine so again
just take about 10 or 15 seconds and
we'll answer we'll go through that
question ok so here very good awesome
ndm is the correct answer which most of
you did get so I'll tell you real
quickly this one it's a little hard to
look at probably because it might be a
little blurry but it also unfortunately
is using the antibiotic codes instead of
their full name here we did a multiplex
pcr it was K pc- and ND m+ and again
your phenotypic clue at how you can look
at this is if you look at your
beta-lactam antibiotics so they're kind
of split across these two rows you'll
notice that all of them are resistant
meropenem is flagging as intermediate
but intermediate is not susceptible so
we would kind of lump that in as an
indicator your Eminem is record being
reported as susceptible even though the
mi c is for and that's just because the
vendors have to utilize the instrument
vendors have to utilize the fda break
points in their reporting not the clsi
but your clue really is as a tree mm
aztreonam remains susceptible only
beta-lactam antibiotics that is
susceptible of the carbapenem aces when
everything else is resistant that's when
you really
I think ndm I won't do the third case it
was here it is again you'll have the
slides with you I will be heading over
to the online learning community after
this I'm sorry I didn't leave too many
times too much time for questions but I
will be over there and I'm happy to
answer any questions in it also my email
address is on the title slide if you
have questions about anything please
don't hesitate to email me I'm happy to
answer them if I can thank you so much
again for the time and opportunity to
present and I am sorry that I went over
thank you for that informative
presentation I would like to thank our
sponsor ascl s for making today's
educational webcast possible please make
sure to head to the community of
learning following this presentation to
have the opportunity to engage in live
chat with nick moore and your peers as
well and get some answers to your
burning questions in regard to
carbapenems producing gnv the nightmare
bacteria here to stay today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through October of this year you'll
receive an email from lab roots to
learning you when the webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye